all rise for the honorable judge ethan
klein
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn
thank you very much welcome everybody to
the content
court today we will be
judging the antics of one the quartering
this is the people versus
the quartering today we
judge jeremy hambly
he is a youtube commentator that mostly
covers current events surrounding
comments
comics video games and the entertainment
industry
he also covers drama and controversies
that occur
both online and in the media he has
multiple channels including unsleeved
media
focus on trading cards and mid wesley
focused on politics
with the most popular being the
quartering which is basically
a channel for being a
little outraged monger
also isn't the quartering like a
tortured uh technique from back in the
day
indeed is that what he's referencing
i'm not sure it also refers to uh
quartering uh
troops in your house in the third
amendment or something
that's really that's not what he's
referring to is it hey i'm gonna stay in
your house y'all
i'm gonna freeload in your house maybe
to his wife that's what it refers to
is considered to be a red-pilled
anti-social justice warrior simp cell
[Music]
the defendant is being charged with the
following crimes
four counts of inverse social justice
ordering which is you know when you're
trying to be a social justice war
when you're trying to be anti-social
justice warrior so hard that you
actually become a social justice lawyer
seven counts of criminal oafishness and
buffoonery
and two counts of explicit simp
celery i feel like i'm saying celery
he's he's being charged with being
celery let us proceed with
opening statements from our prosecution
a b would you like to say some opening
words please
yes thank you your honor today the
people
will advance the argument that jeremy
hambly aka the quartering
aka enslaved media aka
midwesley aka human leftover meatloaf
has on numerous occasions by content
human leftover meatloaf what do you mean
by that
uh he just looks like a meatloaf i don't
know
left over that's hardly appropriate
for this core please abe keep it
professional
i apologize uh with his basement
dwelling neck bearded antics
sorry i'll allow it i'll allow it okay
thank you
i believe your honor you will find the
defendant's behavior speaks for itself
and i asked for and i ask only that you
examine the evidence
as i presented it today thank you
i shall do that i will serve as your
impartial judge now ian
the aien who will be acting as defense
for our
uh the quartering please aien would you
like to make some opening statements
sure thing uh first off i would just
like to say
your honor that you are just glowing
today oh why thank you so much ain
i'll be sure to keep that in
consideration during your arguments
you're looking in every single day
more and more stunning
what is oh are you stifling laughter ian
are you
uh are you making a joke out of your
honor no
no i mean i think it's a good look for
you you look like neo right after you
got out of the matrix bathtub
with those eyebrows i actually like this
look on you
whereas what i hope to do to you someday
actually so
are you you want to harvest my uh
biological energies
yes and you're you're getting there with
each and every day more and more
into character i appreciate that well
you know thank you for saying i look
like neo he is very handsome
and i would love to look like uh keanu
reeve so thank you for saying that
uh no i have a bit of a confession uh
i have no idea who the quartering is
have you not looked up your client
before presenting a defense
well i was going to but uh
a buddy of mine and i decided to
tailgate the apple event
and uh tailgate an apple in a little
while
i didn't know people tailgated apple
events but okay sure
yeah we went down and my friend actually
gets kind of
kind of wild
i have a picture of him here seriously
the energizer bundle your
the energizer bunny you tailgate with
the energizer bunny
yeah he actually strapped a 350 volt
lithium ion battery to my nipples
and uh i you know i went into it
a daze and i woke up just this morning
actually and i rushed over here so i
have no idea who i'm defending or why
but i mean how bad can he be right
you guys are probably just blowing it
out of proportion so
i think this will be an easy easy
defense okay
a very interesting unorthodox opening
statement from aien
we're sure to see a terrific defense
from him well with all the opening
statements uh
closed let us proceed with the trial
this court is now
in session first charge
is inverse social justice warrioring
a b would you like to take it from here
yes thank your honor
so jeremy has a huge vendetta against
so-called social justice warriors so
much so that he has looped around and
became one himself
being that he spends every waking moment
being upset and triggered by the most
inconsequential things imaginable
and i noticed you guys have put a karen
uh
wig on him on the left is that what i'm
witnessing
correct interesting so
moving on um jeremy is a bonafide
culture crusader he gets triggered very
often by stuff that happens in pop
culture
as well as politics but the first
example
if you will move on to the next slide is
about
a remake of the show
she-ra netflix is doing a remake of an
old show
which was about he-man's sister
he is triggered about the redesign he
doesn't like that
the new updated version of the character
doesn't have big boobs anymore
essentially and he wasn't he also
mentions that he wasn't a fan of the
original but he's extremely triggered
by this new iteration fascinating
yeah the title is disgracing she-ra
that's right
disgracing she-ra and strong beautiful
heroes
i see he's achieved a almost 50 dislike
ratio on this one even from his own fans
so
you know it's good oh yeah the fall of
beauty it's called
wow talk about stretching that [ __ ] out
this it's
look it's not like dudes are out there
trying to
you know jerk off to a cartoon i get it
something tells me he is you know
especially like a kid show dude it's not
like hentai bro
but why you took her from being a
princess to an orphan
and then you make her from a beautiful
woman into a man
this is a boy it's an
what there's nothing boyish about the
one on the right
it's really well okay
character that's what this is
and the interesting thing about it is
people who aren't following this
situation
will think oh why are you even
complaining who cares it's a cartoon
well
in some ways i'm pretty don't worry
that's just for people who aren't
following
everyone else following closely along
gets it what he's talking about
i guess you would consider me more
traditional in that
what happened to having powerful strong
and beautiful female role models for
young women to look up to
why must they all be gross
okay i i i this is crazy like okay
first of all what does physical beauty
have to do with being a role model
and second of all the character isn't
even gross by
even i think any definition that's not
totally like i i don't know how to fix
it okay
so let's go to the next slide because i
feel like the art so here
you can see the old art okay
and then the new art so this is an
androgynous lesbian
boy according to him it really just
looks like a modern day
and like this is like kind of the in
style
uh norm of cartoons these days
whereas this is very like 80s yeah
but it's a show for kids clearly so he's
upset they shouldn't have big ass
knockers right i believe in the
in the end of the show she actually um
is a lesbian i mean that's
pretty insignificant but yeah he just
says that it's a it's a strip says this
is a boy
that's not a boy yeah i think it's
[ __ ]
hey watch your language
um but the point is well received that
he's basically just social justice
warrioring
for basically cartoons to be a way that
he likes with big-ass titties
right interesting okay well received
point
so moving on um this video
is titled white guy reviews black
panther 800 percent
woke
eight hundred percent we've never seen
that level woke levels that high before
it's over nine thousand i bet you didn't
know that jeremy was triggered over
black panther's positive reviews
uh he thinks black panther was mediocre
and he even
says that being proud of your skin color
is as stupid as judging someone else's
for theirs
and uh so if you want to take a look at
the video okay interesting
yeah being proud of your skin color
is as stupid as judging someone else for
the color of theirs
could you imagine i mean how
easy are people to control the
overarching message
from mainstream media around the black
panther
phenomena is simply to say
you're black you need to go see this
movie this is a
primary problem i have with labels it's
a problem i have with labeling myself
but with any political ideology and i
don't
label myself by the something as absurd
as the color of my skin something i had
zero conjunction this is um
this is kind of a classic uh argument
that you see
i don't wanna say white supremacist but
it's like a super obtuse way of looking
at skin and
and identity is because being proud of
being white
is like you know white supremacy like
let's be honest that's the heritage
whereas being pl it's not even like
black power it's like hey
we have a moo we have a superhero film
with a
with a black uh lead you know which is
something that that doesn't occur
uh frequently or a movie with all black
casts that
not only that's actually that's a good
movie that people are loving and
watching
and as you know it get little black kids
like having role models and seeing
themselves represented in popular media
so it's easy for him to make that
argument of like it's so
stupid i would never go watch a movie
because there's a white lead in it
is is such an obtuse uh
take because yeah like 90 of all films
have white leads in it right
so it's like cool cool take but
really it's really just not
it's dumb but anyway of course it again
it speaks very well to the social
justice nature of jeremy
making a video ranting about how dare
people like this film
i saw it and i liked it a lot and by the
way the film wasn't
i didn't find the film preachy at all it
was just about black it was about
africans right
and so that that was what what was cool
it wasn't like
super woke or it wasn't like uh
you know the the villain was black too
it wasn't like this trope where it's
like
the white guy's the bad guy and all this
[ __ ] right that would probably set a guy
like jeremy off
that everybody was black in it right
because it's about africans
so god forbid you make a movie about
africans or jeremy here
is going to uh be very angry about it
especially if people like it yeah
i am of course a white supremacist
wow he literally just came out and said
that
i didn't say that but yeah
especially in the marvel universe i mean
how many heroes white heroes do we have
in the marvel
universe he's so triggered that you know
what is there one or two um black heroes
in the in the marvel cinematic universe
sure um and if you look right here i
included a little article that shows uh
a bunch uh on the slide a bunch of
children
i'm sorry oh yeah yeah so as you can see
uh chadwick boseman's untimely and
tragic death the guy who played black
panther
this happened in september and uh
i i just i hope that the quartering can
visit each and every one of these kids
houses
to tell them how stupid it is that they
care about this guy because of his skin
color
you know here i'll give him i'll try to
collect the dresses
oh dumb yeah he i want you to go tell
all these kids
how dumb they are for caring
you know dumb yeah dumb look at all
these idiots caring about black panther
it's crazy that they even that they even
care it's pathetic
um look at this kid who made a tribute
by the way this was a great one
that you know uh go ahead jeremy what do
you think about this
this kid here paying tribute to uh the
black panther
dumb right i think it's really touching
and i think it really
shows how much it means to the kid you
know i wouldn't say it's dumb but
i certainly welcome you to go to all
their houses and tell them to their face
how dumb it is
oh well i actually feel bad it's
all dumb really you're gonna tell that
to a kid who's crying that's so [ __ ]
up dude
yeah i feel bad that was so tragic that
he passed man
so unfair dude
so moving on from this section
um jeremy was triggered by jordan peele
stating i don't see myself casting a
white dude as a lead
in one of his films i the full
statement being that uh not that i don't
like white dudes but i've seen that
movie
it really is one of the best greatest
pieces of the story is feeling like we
are
in this time a renaissance has happened
and proved that myths about
representation in the industry are false
so after making this statement jeremy
decided to respond
on twitter saying uh imagine saying i
don't see myself hiring
white dudes and being applauded these
times dot dot dot
this led to a response from sky williams
who responded to jeremy who said
jordan's message is fine
because there's a massive outstanding
debt to actors of color
he's trying to close the gap by hiring
black leads this isn't a
front to white people but rather a way
to expedite equal representation of
media
want to catch up to y'all you know see i
wouldn't even
go with that i mean that's a totally
valid argument to make
but it's even more simple is that he's a
black man creating films
his experience is that as a black man so
of course he's going to want to make
movies and hire actors
lead actors that represent his life
experience
it's his story it's he's telling it from
his perspective in his life
so of course he's going to hire black
actors and take it to the social justice
warrior the quartering to take it to
twitter
to turn it into some crazy race thing
imagine saying i don't see myself hiring
white dudes and being applauded
you know first of all somebody asked him
and he's like i just
yeah i don't see me why would i why
would i hire white dudes to play leads
in my films because if you
look uh if you look at actors like
martin scorsese he has never had a black
lead in any of his films
yeah i actually had that mentioned in
the next slide
um yes scorsese
spielberg has only had a few you know
it's not an uncommon practice you know
scorsese has said many times that he
tells these uh stories and they take
place in new york and they have to do
with these italians because that's who
he grew up around that's who he knows
it's not uncommon whatsoever he's
telling a story from his perspective you
know
right if you're going to criticize
jordan peele for saying he
wants to cast black main characters in
his films you better at the same time go
and tell score stacey and spielberg he
needs to start casting black
leads which by the way if somebody did
that you would make a video about what a
social justice word they are
so checkmate quartering mate
so yeah on uh slide 11. okay
after uh after jeremy's tweet philip
defranco made a video covering the
situation
and then jeremy decided to make a
response video
and saying that he was simply pointing
out the hypocrisy and what jordan peele
said
so this is the video right here of the
according's response
oh oh
most of the people that know me know i'm
just poking
fun the hypocrisy um
i do take some issues with skye's
statement not like
personal issues but i'm gonna address
them too
because i like skye i think we're
actually on a friendly
uh we do talk back and forth and um
you know he recently unfollowed me but
i think i know sounds like good friends
he's like damn it that's my only black
friend
these are the people that he hits two
boxes for me gay and black
what am i gonna do without him i'm gonna
address them too
because i like skye i think we're
actually on a friendly
uh we do talk back and forth and um
you know he recently unfollowed me but
i think i know why i think he takes a
lot of heat
from people whom in
who run in his circles that really don't
like me um i also think that
maybe sometimes my takes are too spicy
and it bothers them but it was not spicy
that's a good way to call what you do
personally like he literally d on me to
say
that he had to do it and like it was
wholesome
so it was wholesome how he cut me out of
his life
no disrespect to either guy but
you know it's not a false equivalency my
entire point is
simple change one word
imagine uh imagine
me saying hey i just started
exclusivelygames.com
i'm only hiring white people yeah it's
totally different
i mean that is just a totally horrible
comparison
you're talking about hiring someone to
work in retail or
or i don't know behind the scenes in
some way we're literally talking about a
storyteller
expressing his life experience through
an actor
right right the cashier working behind a
counter but you discriminating based on
their
skin color has no justification
it literally doesn't make any sense
straight white males
because i mean by the way he didn't say
anything about straight either dude so i
don't know why you're bringing
sexual orientation into it the entire
industry is full of
uh um you know
and this is why he this is why we call
him a sim cell right because he's
pandering to all these red-pilled
in-cell notions
even though i feel like it's a really
bad faith poorly
thought out argument that's obviously
you know
it's obviously a really bad argument but
what he's doing he's just pandering so
he's a simp cell that's what floats his
boat
that's what keeps his business going
lgbt
or uh women now i guess that wouldn't be
a fair equivalency
okay good cut that out then so anyway
yeah so you got to love his editing
skills he goes here's my argument wait
no that's not a good argument
[Laughter]
i knew something was up so
moving on uh yeah as you mentioned
jordan uh
i'm sorry not jordan jeremy also has a
problem
uh with the lgbt community i guess um
this video
he talks about how he's a problem with
pride month right off the bat actually
starts off pretty well i included some
little details on the right to keep in
mind as you watch this video
um but i think we could just jump right
into it
sure all right i've got to get something
off my chest
black history month is dumb
international men's day dumb
international women's day
dumb gay pride month
dumb it's all done so here's here's what
he's doing first of all i'm glad he was
able to get this off his chest
it's been bothering us so much i mean
what's rattling around in his brain
is truly the the ingredients of a social
justice warrior
you see it all he's laying in bed at
night thinking about how dumb pride
month is
he's got to get it off his chest now his
whole argument is based on
a false equivalency he thinks that
because he's throwing away
international men's day which none of us
have ever heard of by the way and isn't
really a thing
so he's he's making that sacrifice at
the price of black history month
and pride month which are two groups of
historically disenfranchised
prejudice i mean gay and black people
have been literally murdered for being
who they are
so i really don't think that you
throwing away international men's day
and calling that dumb is is a a worthy
sacrifice to be able to call
pride month oh actually the title of
this video is pride month is gay
and it's all he says it's a scam i mean
yeah again sim cell this is this is
classic
selling right it's all
a way for companies to sell you [ __ ]
wrong i cannot believe he's he's tr and
then now it's another false equivalence
he's saying black history month
is the same as valentine's day you know
certainly there's a lot of holidays that
check that box
but saying black when's the last time
you bought a card for black history
month
or gay pride month like that that that's
just
they're so not every holiday is a scam
and like some of them actually
you know is important to us
recognizing these disenfranchised and
and and historically uh discriminated
class classes of people right and once
again his
his the world doesn't exist outside of
his nose because he can't possibly
imagine a world where
being gay or black or is anything
different than his experience
all right that's true there's not more
about foreshadowing aren't aware
that hallmark holidays are the new
uh are the new men's month women's month
black history month
dude you cannot include black history
month with men and women's month
it's not it's just stupid
it's whatever gay month
gay month people don't really buy
hallmark cards anymore most people
my age and younger don't really give a
[ __ ] about
valentine's day haven't given a [ __ ]
about
sweetest day right all of these hallmark
holidays that got people that might be
more personal by products
what that sounds like it might be more
of a personal problem
if he's not celebrating a valentine's
day
[Music]
also foreshadowing interesting no longer
work
what companies figured out however is
virtue signaling
works apparently
if nothing else it's an option for them
to swap in on their marketing calendar
you know a lot of my clients plan their
promotions
a full year in advance many months in
advance usually
and stuff like international men's day
and women's day and black history month
these are easy home run
give them something to talk about
promotions and as a fan
of unfortunately some i have never heard
of any of those
holidays celebrated and the way he's
describing you've got like memorial day
you've got
labor day it's funny he doesn't mention
the actual ones
that people use as marketing like as a
marketing
uh crutch but again i've have you ever
visited a black history month sale
yeah i'm not i'm not really sure what
the commercialization is with uh pride
can you imagine a pride month uh
mattress sale
just ask yourself is there a sale at a
mattress store then you know it's a
commercial holiday by the way he
he mentions that like for example uh gay
pride month
is a uh was created by hallmark
well pride month occurs in the united
states to commemorate june 1969
stonewall riots
as a result many pride events are held
during this month to recognize the
impact that lgbt people have had on the
world
president gerald ford recognized black
history month during the celebration
of the united states bicentennial he
urged americans to seize the opportunity
to honor the two of the neglected
accomplishments
of black americans in every area of
endeavor throughout our history
here we have dc watchtower june 1st you
know i'm sure everybody
uh you know all the little kids out
there love
seeing two men kiss
two one woman and one sort of
woman one man and another man
this i can get down with
i can't i mean you can't make a point
like that and then just say like oh
lesbians are cool
you know what i mean gay dudes suck
lesbians are cool
is my point about pride month you know
naughty dog i'm sure everybody supports
this you know i
follow you naughty dog to learn about
what's going on with the last of us
or uncharted or other video game
things but no
you've got of course to change your logo
chain
you know use this promo code show
everyone there's no promo code for the
record there is no promo code
like i feel like that's a important
distinction to make
they're not trying to sell you bought a
bunch of cookies
or cupcakes for your staff
and you all got together to celebrate so
he is so disturbed by them changing
their logo on twitter
that he needs to make a video about it
he also mentions
that he follows them for stuff about the
last of us the main character of which
is queer
so the main character was like trans
right i mean i didn't play the game i
just saw
media though well one of there is a
trans character in the game but there is
also
the the main girl is a lesbian so i
think it's pretty safe to
assume that that
they care about they actually do care
about these issues jeremy
and unfortunately i don't think they
need to consult you on
i love it he's like i follow you for
news about video games
and you updated your icon to have a
rainbow flag
and now you've ruined it all
that's some social justice warrior talk
all right doesn't get any more well i
would assume there's probably some
evidence of that it's all here baby it's
all here
got together to celebrate
two guys butt [ __ ] i don't know
again you cannot make this point
and at the same time like say homophobic
[ __ ] like that
because it just makes you look like
you're homophobic you all
got together to celebrate two guys butt
[ __ ]
right yeah i do think that undermines
your point a little bit when you make
when you say [ __ ] like that
because it just seems like you don't
like or respect gay people
because i don't think that's what pride
month is about is guys but [ __ ]
i think it's about more than that jeremy
it's all dumb right well to you maybe
okay fantastic so to recap he doesn't
like
movies with black people he doesn't like
black history month or gay pride month
so that is everything okay great so that
concludes our first charges on the
charge of being a social justice warrior
himself
wow aien
what say you on behalf of your defendant
the quartering
[Laughter]
i mean you guys really gave me a doozy
on this one
uh i mean i'm looking back
his problem with the cartoon not having
big enough
frontal torpedoes
i don't know i mean i maybe i can
like i think about one of my favorite
all-time cartoons uh the mom from
rolly pollioli i mean look at the
[ __ ]
curves on her dear
if they redesigned her and made her look
like a normal
you know square robot i'd be a little
peeved
you know he's he's corner chubbed
and he's trying to get to the girthening
you know
because he said he doesn't jerk off to
those cartoons are you
saying on behalf of your client that he
does i'm not going to be
able to offer it even i can't defend
that point
right because obviously he does beat off
to it
yeah so if see he's framing it
incorrectly he needs to just say
yes i do beat off and you guys are
making it harder
and then maybe he'd garner a little more
sympathy
but other than that i don't really have
much
concern can you get a chub
message me after the show and you'll
find out
okay so basically your defense of him is
that
you want to jerk off to robots
uh cartoons and therefore
um have you ever have you ever jerked
off to a cartoon
uh that is not an appropriate question
for entirely honest come on
uh hmm i've ever jerked off the silence
is a little deafening right now i have
to say
i am not on trial here i will remind you
ain and i will hold you in contempt
keep it professional all right all right
so do you did the defense rest i mean
what the hell was that
i mean um
he's trying to go from quarter chopped
to a full mast i don't know
he wants to be the full he wants to be
the
fully torqued instead of the quartering
okay that's right all right
thank you and thank you thank you thank
you
order uh a b how would you respond to
such a
brilliant and articulate defense
um i don't know i guess it was so
baffling that it did leave me speechless
i mean there's so much to speak about i
mean i just
even if we just go off the first point i
just want to remind you guys that
he's offended that a show an anime show
he doesn't watch
doesn't have big boobs anymore in the
reiteration
that's all i have to say okay let's
deliberate now
going back to the beginning the heart of
this charge is
he is someone who is so anti-social
justice warrior
that he himself became an anti-social
justice warrior
or social justice warrior reminds me of
the old saying
beware those who look into the abyss
because the abyss
looks back exhibit one
i'm deep undercover very too deep if you
ask me
he is mad at a cartoon that he used to
like or doesn't even really like because
their boobs are
not big enough anymore
doesn't like the black panther movie
because the lead
is black and he's a shame that pete that
young black
he's embarrassed for young black kids
for having a black role model in popular
media
that's right he thinks that gay
pride month and black history month are
stupid
simply because he doesn't have any use
for mail international wednesday men's
day
well well on this one i have to say it's
a
pretty clear-cut verdict
uh the quartering is without a doubt a
social justice warrior except the causes
he fights for
are just different but the outrage the
trivial
the trivialness is a
plane for anyone to see so this court
decides guilty guilty guilty
absolutely on all
charges of being a social justice
warrior
and i sentence him to you
there's so many bad things that hap are
like he's been banned from so many
conferences and banned from twitter and
stuff so
i sentence him to be banned from twitter
and demonetized
20 billion times
all right let's throw it to a quick
break before we move on to our second
charge
criminal oh fishness and buffoonery well
i'm looking forward to that
we'll be right back after this quick
break
thank you to expressvpn for sponsoring
this
courtroom now i want to tell you guys
quickly about the social dilemma
on netflix i watched this film and it's
very good very good documentary
it's about how tech insiders created
social media
to exploit users data for profit they
call it surveillance
capitalism and you know
with your data is being harvested so
tech billionaires can get
even richer we got to do something about
it
we got to draw the line somewhere folks
that's why we add an extra layer of
protection
with expressvpn because we don't want
those [ __ ] getting any richer
off our back until we get cut in
then i'll turn it off every time you use
the internet big tech companies mine
your data by tracking your search
searches messages and video history but
when you run expressvpn
on your device it hides your ip address
which
websites can use to personally identify
you
yes i'm talking specifically to you zach
i know what you get to on the internet
and it's weird and trust me you don't
want other people to know too
that's why i recommend zach for in
particular turn on expressvpn
that makes your activity more yeah you
with me that you copy that
100 yeah data i don't want people
knowing that you're watching
uh dr jason's only fans
[Laughter]
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers
you still need to be careful with what
you share in social media but with
expressvpn
you can make your browsing more
anonymous
express expressvpn also encrypts 100 of
your internet
data to keep you safe from hackers and
prying eyes
many vpns slow down your internet but
with expressvpn it's incredibly
fast and easy to use just tap one button
and boom you're protected
so if you don't like the idea of big
tech companies exploiting your personal
information then visit expressvpn.com
h3 right now and you can get three
extra months of expressvpn for free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 to protect your data go to
expressvpn.com
h3 to learn more and get
three extra months for free
we are back from our break and here with
our second charge
criminal o fishness and buffoonery a b
would you like to introduce this charge
for the jury yes
thank you jeremy hambly is deeply
embarrassing human being
his day-to-day consists of cartoonish
amounts of stepping on rakes
head bonking and self owned
thank you zac with these charges of
criminal oafishness and buffoonery
i will demonstrate that jeremy's
bumbling antics and subsequent
blustering proves beyond a reasonable
doubt that jeremy is deserving of a
conviction so the charge is basically
that he's just
like a ding-dong he's a dum-dum
okay interesting this should be great
love it
moving on to slide 15.
so in this section we'll take a look at
jeremy's harassment of cosplayer
christine sprinkle
which ultimately led to jeremy being
banned from magic the gathering
wow that is i have to say an achievement
maybe that i've never heard of before he
was banned from all magic the gathering
events
yep wow that's the media
he made a video calling out christine uh
that's since been removed by youtube
uh for violating uh the harassment
bullying policy
um the video was titled playset of beta
white knights prevent rape of mtg
cosplayer sprinkle
and um yeah and he made many tweets
about the situation
so the videos what does that title mean
what is a playset of beta white knights
what is a playset
is that a magic the gathering
terminology oh
maybe actually playset of beta white
knights present prevent
rape why would you even put rape in the
title that's so [ __ ]
creepy what a weirdo
i don't even know you could put rape in
the title to be honest well it was
removed so apparently you can't
so you want me to play okay yeah
it's jeremy getting all defensive
the latest thing that sent me off on
patreon is a female cosplayer
in the magic community crying on our
video asking for money
let's be very clear here one if
she wasn't a good looking girl the
support would be
about five percent of what it really is
and two if she wasn't also crying
same thing holds true if i i said it
better in a tweet but basically
if you are an average looking woman or
any man
you would not have garnered hundreds of
patrons overnight
okay serial virtue signaler
and crying for patreon dollars cosplayer
c.s frankel run posted yesterday
a lot of messages to my facebook page
again
question my life choices immediately
sprinkle is a pro cosplayer you know
she's a professional cosplayer
by the fact that she has to solicit
patreon dollars and then
cry in her patreon video to get loser
beta
cucks to give her money but you know
what [ __ ] these
dude i got a people dude this guy
calling anyone a beta [ __ ]
i mean like i'm not i'm not someone that
walks around with the whole alpha male
energy i find that whole notion of
malpha and beta really dumb
but like dude nobody gives me more beta
small dick energy
than jeremy i mean let's just be honest
let's come on guys
you this guy calling anyone a beta [ __ ]
is crazy
i don't think she has any sexual
interest this guy pees soy milk you know
what i mean
like it's just what runs through his
veins her money
give her your money and don't you dare
objectify her look at i mean it is like
a all-time white knight
gold rush for these losers that think
they have any real chance
at penetrating this woman penetrating
yeah i don't think her fans being
supportive necessarily think they
that they all can have sex with her and
by the way aren't all
like cosplay girls like they have a
patreon that's how their business works
they don't get paid they don't
have a way to monetize their work people
support them on patreon that's pretty
normal right
yeah oh yeah definitely i mean it's one
of the most popular ways of course
we tried to find evidence of her crying
we were unable to find like the
original video that set him off but
something tells me it wasn't really as
bad as
as what he made it out to be and anyway
what is his why is he getting so fired
up just let this girl be
enraged that i recorded a patreon video
crying and begging [ __ ] losers for
their money
oh yeah you're such a hero cuz sprinkler
you're such a hero
i don't see her claiming to be a hero
anywhere
talk to some people about the cosplay
thing i think cosplay is great
it's it's great it's not really a
service
in my opinion it's someone who likes to
play dress-up i think a lot of people
see this fat material in my opinion
when i start looking at some of this
cosplay i start having to say like i
feel a little movement down in my
pantaloons and i'm like i see why
i see one so this this is a trend i've
noticing it was where he has a lot of
rage towards people
he's attracted to i think he has like i
know he's married right but he has like
in-cell energy where he like
he he targets attractive women that he
knows he would have no chance with that
women who would probably despise him if
they ever met him which is true
because not because of his looks or
anything but just because he's such an
[ __ ] right such a chauvinistic
[ __ ] and he has a lot of rage for
them and she is kind of the subject of
his rage here
because it's like i don't respect what
you do but i'll beat off to it
it's just odd you know it's just really
a rageful
perspective yes moving on on november 24
2017 christine tweeted that she was
unloading her magic the gathering
costumes and cosplay gear in the wake of
months of harassment
sprinkle who has been contracted by
wizards of the coast in the past and is
considered one of the most popular
cosplayers in the magic scene
spoke out about harassment she suffered
after jeremy posted a grading video
about her and other cosplayers
so this situation as i mentioned prior
has led to the
banning of jeremy from magic the
gathering and down here
are different tweets from sprinkle and
from
magic gathering so his whole video which
has been removed from youtube and kind
of scrubbed from the internet
i've read descriptions of it and from
what i could tell he was looking at
cosplayers and basically just
objectifying and talking
looking at like uh like you know
lewd photos of them and making sexual
comments about them and the whole thing
was just really creepy and odd
she tweeted out it's been a rough year
and i've blocked
and not said anything about him because
i wanted it to die
but without a doubt mtg headquarters on
sleeve media that's him
has made my life hell this year this
whole year
with his unnecessary videos tweets about
me and other members of magic
so that's what she said about him
apparently he's just been
uh harassing her for an entire year
because she was making money on patreon
in a way that he thought was
inappropriate
saturn and then magic the gathering of
fish or
what was that
what was that poor [ __ ] why did you say
it like that
magic the gathering tweeted out were
saddened poor by what happened in the
magic community this weekend
cyber bullying and harassment are
unacceptable and we support those who
come forward with their experiences
no one should be made to feel unsafe or
welcome we're working to be part of the
solution yeah i mean magic the gathering
seems like an exclusive environment i
don't really think they want people like
jeremy
out to make like she's like a really
engaged
you know really kind of a fun player in
the scene right
they probably love people like her she's
super into it she does cosplay she shows
up to the events people get excited to
see her
and then you've got these [ __ ] like
jeremy on the sideline just [ __ ] on
her
for having a patreon because it's not a
service apparently to him
it's not a service what the [ __ ] do you
do is it a service
you know what i mean what do you what
does that mean
so next page i have no idea what
happened there
so moving on to 17
um slide 17 after he was banned he went
on crusade
against magic the gathering and wizards
of the coast
accusing the company of harboring
pedophiles
although jeremy teased it the article he
made an article about i'm sorry
and although he teased it the article
lacked any credibility to the extent
that even the daily stormer refused to
run it
so let me get this straight he got
banned from magic the gathering and then
tried to run a story about how they're
harboring pedophiles
right he's like i know i am that
pedophile
yeah i was a member of that community
for years
uh here's his tweet on sleeved media i
guess i shouldn't spoil the upcoming
article tomorrow on the daily stormer
about mtg
shh i don't want all the roaches to
private their accounts
now daily stormer who he brags about his
article was going to be published there
who they rejected let me read a blurb
here about the daily stormer this is
from wikipedia or what
i think yeah it's just this is like this
is established
don't don't think that i'm exaggerating
here this is what the daily stormer is
it's an american far-right neo-nazi
white supremacist holocaust denial
commentary message board that advocates
for the genocide of jews
me by the way it considers itself a part
of the alt-right movement
its editor andrew anglin founded it on
july 4
2013 as a faster-paced replacement for
his previous website total fascism
that doesn't really mince words does it
which had focused
on his own long form essays on fascism
race and anti-semitic conspiracy
theories
so this is the website
that jeremy was eager to post his story
on
a story that was so incredible
that even they denied it by the way this
old twitter account was banned
and just we went to the daily stormer
and what we saw on the very homepage
kind of gave us a chuckle so we wanted
to show it
they have a live countdown demographic
to when america becomes a
not a non-white majority country
and i will tell you guys that we have
about how much time does it say there i
can't see it
22 years oh 22 years about 23 years
until
until that happens so don't worry
jeremy's
gonna have a full life ahead of you
yeah so after this uh
whole crazy situation if we move on to
slide 18
recording was also banned from gen con
um ncon is a large tabletop gaming
convention
uh he was banned for being getting in a
physical altercation
with another attendee and also
um he was accused of harassing
other people in gen con as well online
so he's not only banned from magic the
gathering for life
he's banned from gen con for life
right fantastic
i mean i don't know anyone that's banned
from any events let alone two
you know do you know anyone that's uh
defended weinstein because he did no
not one okay well moving on there's a
little uh
video i have for you right here where
jeremy is defending harvey weinstein
oh is this a picture of him and harvey
together i didn't know they were friends
best buds they look really happy
together
maybe that's how he has the intel on
magic the gatherings uh pedophile ring
that he was
yeah i mean i happen to know they've
been harboring pedophiles
i'm one of them hurts his views on
mr weinstein's alleged victims and that
adults who made choices and why he's
tired as a white man for being blamed
for everything that's wrong with the
world
round of applause for harvey these were
ambitious adults
there are how many victims in harvey's
life and i feel sympathy for them
but hollywood is full of very ambitious
people who are adults
and they make choices if you read read
between the lines here what he's saying
is
people knew what they were getting into
when they serviced
the man and they even i'm pretty sure
he's accused of rape
like i think there's two issues here
that he's not addressing
he's like yeah you can be coerced or or
consent to a sexual situation you don't
want to be in
but he's actually accused of raping
people dude so
kind of missing the point there yeah he
tends to do that
how many victims in harvey's life and i
feel sympathy for them
but hollywood is if you re read between
the lines here what he's saying is
people knew what they were getting into
when they serviced the man
and they either for better or worse got
what they had hoped or didn't
but nonetheless as adults they made
their own decision
and now they're looking to blame
everybody else for that
but shouldn't the men who did the things
take responsibility
gilliam doesn't think so he said when
you have power
you don't take responsibility for
abusing others you enjoy the power
that's the way it works in reality he's
probably not wrong there either it's
pretty pretty based
uh pretty bass straight
yeah something tells me something tells
me that harvey weinstein is legit one of
jeremy's
like role models i think he's envious of
him
it's male privilege by the way that
doesn't exist i understand that men
have had more power longer but i'm tired
as a white man of being blamed for
everything that's wrong with the world
again hard to disagree round of applause
well he has done the impossible and
mounted offense forever his views on
he called him he goes abusing his power
to
to coerce women to doing sex with him is
based and uh he actively
did a clap a round of applause for
harvey
uh because he thinks he's a white male
being blamed for all the problems in the
world
actually you're being charged for rape
so let's just call an apple an apple or
cigar cigar what they say
excellent i think a better quote would
be
the true measure of a man is what he
does with power uh
oh what was that from is that from like
spider-man or something
um i think it wasn't a game actually but
it is a common i think soccer was
socrates yeah i mean no that's a that's
a really good point and jeremy's like
listen
i would probably coerce people to have
sex with me
that's why you get power
beast baby
all right oh peeing on the floor of his
basement this sounds fantastic
yeah this is more uh a beat i guess you
could say
oh sure so um
yeah i think you should watch the video
yeah i think i kind of was
self-explanatory let's go ahead
excellent maybe i'm gonna pee in my
trash can down here i don't know
my wife went out for pizza without me
and i'm angry about it
so i'm gonna win this round and i'm
gonna pee
if i don't win this round i'm gonna pee
in my own basement
i i don't have a toilet down here all i
have is a drain in the floor
what
i feel like we're gonna have to use it
though i feel like we're gonna have to
use it
holy [ __ ]
so appreciate what's happening
he's in the basement of his house his
wife has
has partitioned him to the basement
his wife cocked him for some pizza and
he's just taking it in the basement
and he's so embarrassed he won't go
upstairs to use the toilet he's peeing
in a drain in the basement
and he this guy calls people [ __ ]
do you think that it's urine or soy
coming out of his penis
that's a tough one it's peed in my
basement
no not in the kitty litter just uh in
the drain
in the drain so you know he splashed
urine
everywhere he sits there you can't pee
into a drain a floor drain
and not splash pee everywhere and he
just sat back down he's literally just
sitting amongst urine it smells like
urine he's
in a public restroom basically playing
video games
i think i heard a fart in there too and
no wonder his wife went to pizza without
him the dude
is sitting in his own filth was that a
fart
yeah i think i heard a fart in there i i
isolated that uh
let's hear it
oh go one more time oh let me boost it
oh yeah definitely fart
like after he sits back down that's
awesome
look if you want to watch a streamer
that wants to pee in the potty
go watch someone else and by the way who
said the guy doesn't have kids he has no
right to be saying potty
to be honest with you all maybe i'm
gonna pee in my trash can down here i
don't know
at least he didn't be in the trash can
if i can be give him some credit
that's more disgusting uh someone did a
clip
and up and upload this to youtube and he
even went out of his way
to comment on it imagine thinking this
is an own
i mean i hate to break it to you dude
but it is pretty disgusting
it made it to our slide
if you go to the next slide you'll see
uh him addressing the situation on
twitter
wow okay so somebody said so your
argument is because he got drunk and
peed his pants once
oh is that true that's happened his
opinion is invalid
wait a minute now i didn't that didn't
even happen lol these morons think me
pissing in my basement drain one time
on stream when i was drunk
is some sort of own like so [ __ ] what
i'm happy to do it again
should i feel the need to i mean it does
say something about you dude
i just peed in my basement yeah i mean
it really does say something about you i
have to say
someone said a burger king sponsorship
would be much better than pissing on
your own basement floor during a live
stream
it says yes i have a section of the
basement that is unfinished in the home
that i own all basements have a drain
pipe i pissed in it in the home that i
own
how is that supposed to be a burn checks
bio oh yeah i mean i don't really care
if you own the house it's disgusting and
you have problems dude
someone said was it even more
embarrassing than pissing on your own
basement floor during a live stream he
said
it's every homeowner's right to pee in
their basement
you would know if you owned a property
yeah dude nobody's saying it's not your
right
and the police are not coming to arrest
you for being in your basement
the point is that it's embarrassing and
disgusting
and your response kind of proves the
point that it is you're an embarrassing
human being
right like my wife went out for pizza
without me
um i guess you're right to take a [ __ ]
on the couch it doesn't mean you should
yeah i mean you could [ __ ] down the
basement and walk you could [ __ ] down
the drain and waffle stomp it down that
is your right as a homeowner
you know what i mean you have a lot of
rights as a homeowner
right you know going on um
jeremy has a habit of accidentally
owning himself on twitter
um you use the word cuck
i think that may be uh potentially uh
appropriate
if you look at these tweets right here
let's see um starting with the one where
he's in the back seat
so uh the wife joins the tesla family i
even fit in the back seat
i mean why are you sitting in the back
seat you you've [ __ ] why are you like
if you're such an alpha male shouldn't
you be driving let alone she's like no
no no no jeremy your ass is in the back
seat
your honor if i may enter interject and
submit to
the court um when we were looking at
these i've never
laughed so hard in my life i fell over
in my chair we had we had to have a mute
his mic because he want to stop laughing
noted thank you so he goes on to say
take that wife's tesla wait a minute
it's a hundred dollars i guess
she's saying that you don't have to pay
for gas the wife bought me
home culver's after flying and delivered
it to me as i played video games
that is [ __ ] peak
brought me home culver's what does that
mean it's something
the fast food joint oh home culvers
after flying and delivered it to me
wife's out flying this morning so i got
up early to play some video games
married life
my wife asked just asked why her lotion
was down in my office
and she refuses to believe that it was
for a bit in spite of video evidence
yeah dude
you definitely beat off with the lotion
it's clearly not the first time it's
happened that's why she doesn't believe
you
he's like a little boy
yo why would you even tweet that bro
yeah he's a little boy he's in the
backseat of the car he's pissing all
over the place
he has maybe fast food burgers so he can
play some video games
right
dude why are you beating off with your
wife's lotion bro
that's an am that's a rookie mistake bro
you got to put the lotion back where you
found it
maybe maybe she locked him in the
basement for doing that that was his
punishment so
that's why he had to pee no i'm sure so
i'm sure that's what happened like
you know why he hates women so much is
because
his wife puts him in the basement
because he just pees everywhere
oh this is okay so we have here jeremy
is triggered
by music composer michael giaccio
tweeting [ __ ] hitler yes
let's see michael tweets out great news
see king kong in theaters for the first
time
in nearly 65 years max steiner
essentially created the template for
film scoring
with this masterpiece somebody responded
with hitler's favorite movie
and he responded by saying [ __ ] hitler
okay now the could that set off the
quartering he quote tweeted [ __ ] hitler
and said
and there we have it yikes
saying [ __ ] hitler is yikes
from the guy by the way who was
desperate to be published
on a website that believes in jewish
genocide
so just fine
i am of course a white supremacist yeah
i mean just follow the bread comes on
that one
someone said you unironically leap to
defend hitler you have no right to be
yikes seeing anybody turd
to which he responded hitler was
nominated for a nobel peace prize what
the [ __ ] have you ever done
well if you're gonna list that as an
achievement you may as well list the
other stuff he's done too
that's crazy to tweet that and this year
he must have been drunk man again
he must have just got done peeing in his
basement taking a dump in his basement
drying drain
jerking off with his wife down the drain
that drains scene [ __ ] man that drain
has seen [ __ ] none of us deserve
if that drain had eyes
amazing how this [ __ ] hitler tweet has
taken hold with people completely
incapable of understanding my point
which was obvious to everyone that
follows me
hollywood types saying [ __ ] hitler for
retweets is [ __ ] stupid and cringe
it's about virtue signaling
he literally just responded to a guy
aren't you doing the same thing by the
way aren't you virtue signaling
to your sim cells about how woke you are
and i mean i feel like he
that's what he's doing is like this
anti-virtual
he's an anti-virtue signaling signaler
you know that's right
man i never heard i never imagined a day
where someone's saying [ __ ] hitler would
be met with a yikes
but there you have it especially from
the same guy who's upset about an anime
character's
boob size so
he gets triggered by something like that
but he
wants to call someone else out for
saying f hitler well we do well yeah and
and also i want to say congratulations
to hitler on his nobel peace prize
before we go on next because that is how
he's remembered of course for
for his his contributions to world peace
all right next moving on
jeremy has two emerge imaginary gay
black dads
fantastic yeah so this is a twitter
thread right here
where someone was investigating his
claims of having
two gay black dads um this is his actual
thumbnail by the way
his two jacked black dudes
my gay black dads and then he has this
habit of using
emojis in his thumbnails which is like
beyond cringe
and so it's like a winky face should i
play this video
i would start with the twitter thread if
you want to get some more contacts i'll
click this link here okay yeah
okay so apparently jeremy has been
claiming unironically
that he has two gay black dads
which i'm assuming is
well here you can tell dude is desperate
getting more and more absurd in his
pathetic attempt to bully me into a
debate
now it's i think homosexual is
disgusting absolutely [ __ ] disgusting
i love and support my
lgbtq viewers i also have two dads
so who is gay
yeah i mean you might you might think
he's just kidding around but he
continues
over a cold span of time
you know this is from the following
month he says understanding your fans
makes you a chill also homophobe but
i'll have you know i have two dads
you're like okay
it's weird he keeps saying that fast
forward to the next month
actually two months later then the story
evolves one of my dads is black
and gay is your other dad gay as well i
hope so
that'd be weird
oh is that it or is it just for this
thread
yeah he continues on he continues on
this is from december now this is over
the span of half a year
wait till he finds out i have two black
dads that i love dearly
my dads are black it's crazy november
this is
a continuous thread the irony is lost
and this is just turned into a straight
up
real claim
it doesn't know my dads are black my
dads are black you can
yada yada yada i have two dads my dads
are black this is a claim that he
continues to put forward
but then all of a sudden someone dug up
this tweet
of him showing a picture of his dad not
black
i can't speak to his sexual orientation
my dad soldiered up and took my niece to
disney
he's gotten used he gotta use a carton
auction but that doesn't mean i won't
roast him for the picture love you dad
certainly not a black man he might be
gay i don't know
why are you gay he says so now all of a
sudden jeremy has
three dads two are black
one is white they're in a they're in a
throuple
three throw up he has three dads that
are all gay and two of them are black
is this story adding up to anyone lastly
i want to point out that there
is a way in which all this could be true
maybe his mom divorced his
biological dad and then they got into a
three-way
with two people of color giving him the
benefit of doubt of course
as much as possible didn't he respond to
that one
well he responded on the video form
that's that's okay
so before you open the video can i draw
your attention to the thumbnail
uh one more time yes please by all means
um it's essentially
his white gay dad
blasting a load right on the test of his
one of his black gay dads you know it
doesn't seem very respectful to his gay
black dads to portray them like
like that my gay black dads with a winky
face let's enjoy the journey shall we
is that what it is and then he posts a
picture
of my white dad according to jeremy he
also has this dad i don't know maybe he
has three dads
someone makes sense to me now this
is one of my dad's all right handsome
man
a man that would give you the shirt off
his back
and so he also enjoys the company of two
other
black men who are you vadim
leslie i can't [ __ ] believe this [ __ ]
i mean this is insane
you guys have to appreciate that this
has been an ongoing argument of his
like over the course of an entire year
there's no irony there's no sense of a
joke
he's literally saying he has three dads
three gay dads two of them are black
no pictures by the way with his gay
black dads
and his story has morphed over time
where one of his dads was gay
then he was had two black gay dads and
now he has three dads
i mean he's blessed you know we're all
should be so blessed to have so many
loving parents
i mean not many of us can claim three so
there is a way in which all of this
could be true
maybe his mom divorced his white dad and
they both both went on to marry two pocs
this is the only way it can work
why are you that worried about my dad's
video let me tell you something man my
because you keep using it as a
as a shield of criticism saying that
you're the one
saying every week on twitter that you
have all these gay black dads in your
life
you know what i mean i mean it's not
like he just randomly is curious about
it
and i mean i would throw the question
back to you why do you care about the
size of a cartoon female's
breasts family
is none of your business all right and
stop talking about it on twitter and
using as a shield
[ __ ] hell this is so bizarre i mean
could you guys appreciate how bizarre
this guy's claiming to have three
gay dads two of them are black
you would think they would teach him to
be more um tolerant
of other people
well how can you say that his experience
he has so many black gay men in his life
he's just surrounded by black gay dads
that's what i'm saying you think they
would teach
he would have turned out to be more
tolerant
i'm surprised he doesn't think he's a
gay black got together to celebrate
two guys butt [ __ ] right
very well stated from a man with three
gay dads
play that again zach what is black
history what is a gay history month
again
you all got together to celebrate two
guys butt [ __ ]
right that's what it's about you think
like
like his dad's birthday parties he gets
up and says that
yeah yeah no he tells them hey guys
happy birthday
to my gay black dads i just want you to
let you know that black history month
and gay pride month are dumb
thank you very much but wait there's
more
the quartering says everybody should do
blackface for halloween
literally he tweeted out literally
nobody's actually offended by blackface
what you're just one
white dude like i mean how can you speak
for every black person
calm down i actually think everybody
should do blackface for halloween
blackface and full indian headdress in
the same costume
stop clutching pearls alrighty then
says the guy who made a whole video
about cartoon characters titties not
being big enough for him
here he is saying that athletes are
uneducated on politics and shouldn't
speak on politics just put the ball in
the hole
all i said is i don't give a [ __ ] what
millionaires with very little education
have to say about modern politics
you think i give a [ __ ] what the nba has
to say about politics put the ball in
the hole
that is all yet the quartering himself
obviously discusses politics all the
time even though he has studied
marketing in college and has no degree
in political science
which is of course what he's saying i
mean most athletes are college educated
right so
i'm not sure what his credentials are
now we were able to locate
jeremy's linkedin profile and i would be
remiss for not showing you he considers
himself
an elite strategic internet marketing
uh expert and
let me remind you of jeremy's thumbnails
and remember he's an elite marketing
consultant who puts
emojis in his thumbnails he is the most
hideous
ugly horrible thumbnails i've ever seen
bar none
without a doubt he has
emoji the only person i've ever seen
putting emojis in his thumbnails is
soflo antonio
but ironically i guess soflo would
consider himself a marketing genius too
so
excellent eh good ship here he is saying
he was dropped by dollar shave club for
not being woke enough dollar shave club
lull sorry he started with lol dollar
shave club dropped me because i wasn't
woke enough but happily gives tana
mongoo
a sponsorship in a video where she is
smoking weed saying she can't live
without it
and then talking about shaving her [ __ ]
i don't see
how why any of those issues have to do
with being woke
he says i'm still kind of salty then he
quickly uh
corrects himself after what i'm assuming
is dollar shave club telling him he
needs to
correct the record he goes
after a week dollar shave club replied
on why they terminated
my partnership they claim it is because
of performance
and not because of my political
affiliation
the data supports their claim they
shared the data with me
i am unsure why they didn't tell me that
in the first place wow you are a [ __ ]
idiot
how much you want to bet the dollar
shave club made him tweet that
they're like dude you can't tweet out
that we dropped you because of your
we made a video about it too of course
yeah of course
obviously oh wow
what an idiot oh quitting twitter we
love it
yeah so as as we've noticed he tends to
make a fool of himself on twitter a lot
so he decided to quit twitter um if you
watch this video he'll give some of his
reasons as to why
okay fantastic he says the toxicity of
twitter has most likely bled over to
real life
[Music]
he refers to people on twitter refer to
turkey on thanksgiving as racist or
wrapping paper
a symbol of white colonialism he says
that twitter used to once consist of
heartwarming cat videos
no that was never what twitter was
what yeah twitter's always been about
text
over the last few years has turned into
a cesspool of ragebay and faith
destroying videos oh no jeremy's faith
in god is being
shaken by twitter alrighty let's watch
leaving the cesspool goodbye twitter is
a cesspool
twitter is full of sad hateful
people upset their lives haven't turned
out the way
that they had hoped and so they are
driven
to like crabs in a bucket
pull down anyone else who may be wrapped
in a bucket
who may just have broken the terrible
terrible
law of being happy enjoying things
just look what's being shared there used
to be a time where you would see
excellent cat videos and and
and and heartwarming moments but over
the last year it's basically turned into
an
endless cesspool of rage bait
and i'm pretty sure that just has to do
with who you follow dude
just follow cute cat [ __ ] accounts if
that's what you want to see bro
that's how twitter worked man uh faith
destroying videos opinions
it's no longer not positive
and i'll be leaving it twitter i love
this epic proclamation
i am leaving twitter
and i'm proclaiming it for all
he made a whole video about it should i
keep watching or is that enough that's i
think that's enough
that's enough yeah so he just goes into
some some research as to the negative
effects of twitter
not very interesting whatever we all
know twitter sucks i mean that's not
obviously uh that's that's not a
controversial statement that that being
on social media is bad for you
you know i think we all agree on that so
he's leaving the cesspool
but wait timeline of events
yeah so july 27th he tweets that he's
quitting twitter
that's the video we just watched six
days later
there he tweets uh promoting a new video
let's look at this he tweets out
a new video about george rr martin being
cancelled
okay so people are like hmm i thought
you were off twitter
the next day he tweets the account quote
tweeted by his twitter account
is ran by a single mom named maggie
and this is when it gets bizarre to the
point of having three gay dads
[Music]
just so everyone knows jeremy no longer
manages this account my name
is maggie i am a single mom that jeremy
graciously offered a full-time position
to help me out
please direct your hate elsewhere dude
he is so crazy
why would you ha first of all why would
you need to say that you're a single mom
and second of all why would you be
needing to be hired full time to tweet a
couple of times a day
somebody was making fun of him they said
hey everyone he's back on twitter
and he's this is still his pinned video
so maggie had to step in to simp for uh
the quartering aka
himself two days after that
he gave an update about a video he's
making
on twitter i have privatized both videos
on this person he doesn't need to feel
like he has to do the same
oh did he have beef with this person i'm
sure i think we're good after talking at
dms
never should have even made the videos
i'll give
i'll give back with a more positive
video this afternoon jeremy
okay he's clearly tweeted
uh oh and here comes a statement from
maggie the single mom
hi this is jeremy maggie handles 99 of
my pulse
but i pushed her into the corner so i
could say hi
creepy why'd you push her in the corner
freak
dude he's literally just this is like
when somebody um
when they leave a supportive comment
under their comment but forget to log
out
you know burner account
a next day he makes his triumphant
return by the way what happened to
maggie
the single mom he gave a full-time job
to he just kicked her to the [ __ ]
curb
i thought he did this great charitable
act for maggie
and he's like nah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you're
fired this is jeremy
clown on him for the brittany venti
thing that's more funny
yeah he's just tweeting like nothing
happened right
yeah that's it he's back in it
and then 10 days later he finally
acknowledges
said yes i'm back to twitter are people
not allowed to change their mind
not very progressive what i just want to
know what happened to maggie
what happened to that poor single mom
holy [ __ ] you guys great
scott in the words of the
the dog yeah that's right
holy [ __ ] all right that was great
on the count of criminal oafishness and
being just an overall stooge in goober
aien what say you on behalf of your
client the quartering
um well you guys
you guys gave me a lot there's a lot in
here
sure it's a lot of stuff
right it's a lot right oh yeah
for sure well
i actually as i said i'm not familiar
with him but i went to check out his
channel
and i actually counted
and he has uploaded 47 videos in the
last week
wow so if he's keeping that rate
almost 50 videos a week i guess my only
uh defense would be that
all things considered his amount of oh
fishness is way
lower than you'd expect you'd think you
would be saying
dumbass [ __ ] nonstop 50 videos a week is
crazy so
i don't know relative to that
maybe he's holding it together more
often than we give him credit for
hmm well it's just then again
maybe there's 45 videos in there that we
just didn't get to so
i don't really know so your argument on
one hand you say we're
cherry picking but on the other hand you
started by saying
there's a lot so those two statements
seem to be in contradiction of each
other
oh i mean there's a lot there's a lot of
volume right sure
okay thank you for that statement uh ian
i will ain i will bear that in mind as i
deliberate a b closing statements
uh yeah you told us to try to keep it
around the hour that's the only reason
why we don't have more stuff
we would have had a lot more oh there's
much much more
eh much more hmm that's all out of it
have you watched all 50 videos of this
week's
dude i only have one life
sure yeah even with your ungodly uh
ability of superhuman even of consuming
data at a quick rate you wouldn't even
do that
that would burn my battery so fast sure
may i ask the defense um are you would
you consider yourself woke
ain well i never sleep so
[Laughter]
excellent all right i'll deliberate now
thank you everybody
on the uh charge of criminal oh fishness
and being an overall goob
the evidence is is vast and compelling
to kind of to summarize
we got he's banned from all magic the
gathering events
um he is banned
from gen khan
he pursues the daily stormer
for to print his articles
a self-described neo-nazi
publication he mounted a defense for
harvey weinstein which i will say is
brave if nothing else
he has peed on the basement floor
on a live stream and he when he even
went out of his way to comment on the
video
imagine thinking this is a note
ironically
the comment itself being an epic cell
phone
i just peed in my basement
uh he sits in the back seat of his
wife's car
she doesn't allow him in the front seat
he's forced to sit in the back seat
and he uses his wife's lotion to jerk
off
gets caught and then tweets about it
he says saying that's right he he says
yikes when people say [ __ ] hitler
he celebrates hitler's uh uh being
nominated for a nobel peace prize
he claims continuously to have
two gay black dads three dads in total
[Music]
but then he says why are you caring
about my family so much when people
ask him why does he keep tweeting about
gay black dads
[Music]
oh boy and so much more
he quit twitter he hired a single mom
maggie
to run his twitter account and fired her
a week later
great scott dumb
the evidence is compelling and
overwhelming
this court finds jeremy absolutely
guilty on the charge of being an
absolute [ __ ] dip
guilty guilty guilty guilty it's
[ __ ]
watch your language jeremy that's not
appropriate
[ __ ] i sent it to you to a lifetime
of living in the basement and sitting in
the back seat
of your wife i sentence you to a life of
soy and [ __ ] dumb
as you so scream against others
thank you and on to our
on to our third and final charge
explicit
simp celery so moving on to our third
and final charge jeremy has demonstrated
a habitual tendency
to become fixated on gatekeeping
successful women who violate his safe
spaces
though his obsession with christine
sprankle cost him his livelihood as a
magic the gathering personality
the subsequent fallout and attention
that gained him from certain circles led
to an awakening of sorts
jeremy's awakening to the lucrative
world of grifting adsense money from
incels
however today the people will argue that
in a few instances his obsession has
gone far beyond drifting in cells and
has drifted into
explicit stem cell territory fascinating
i see on the right pokey main and brie
larson seem to be
the subjects of his uh his attention
to put it lightly here you can see
jeremy has made over 20 videos on
pokeman
pokeman meltdown full cairn mode pokeman
refuses to apologize
instant karma for pokeman pokeman huge
sponsor drop
pokemon hacked and twitch responds
pokemane
should be banned from twitch yikes et
cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
the next slide has um some of his some
of the more uh
oh yeah let me remind you that he is a
marketing guru
as you as you observe these thumbnails
pokemon meltdown totally absurd i don't
know why he gave her
her like ice what is the arrow pointing
i see eyes
pokemon roasted by fans she's bleeding
from her mouth
jesus bro pokemon twitch
simps delete critical channel what
journals attack leafy
alrighty fantastic
some of the quarter earrings tweets
about pokemon
there isn't a more manipu manipulative
hypocritical content creator i've come
across than pokeman
the question is am i willing to take the
impending channel strike to roaster
of course he thinks that he that
anybody who dares make a video about
pokeman gets a strike which is
in which is absurd shouldn't he have
like 20 plus strikes then
right good point i mean he has 20 videos
about her channel should have been
erased
uh no she's not the most manipulative
hypocritical content creator i mean tone
it down dude
she tweeted out all my bras undies and
socks were lost
in the move wtf he said check ebay
pretty creepy i'm assuming he's been
checking ebay
for some of her used panties
he goes on pokeman apology video voice
sounds real different than anything i've
heard
hmm i guess he's implying that she's
being de
decept or uh yeah deceptive because he's
he's studied her so closely he's
listening
to her tenor and her figure of speech
and it just sounded
so very different than all the other
videos he's obsessed over
he says i've gotten to a wild beta by
applying and getting lucky
that is like most of us but why are
people [ __ ] on asthma and gold is
beyond
me obviously dude gets an instant invite
you people do know wow has to sell the
product right
[ __ ] that vapid pile of bricks pokemon
got in
dude vapid pile of bricks
i'm deep undercover dude you pee in a
drain bro
yeah and of course she got on too why
can he why is he defending the guy and
on the other hand
saying [ __ ] pokeman i mean she's a huge
gamer
even way bigger than asthma and gold so
yes jeremy was quick to jump on the tier
3 sub train pokeman exposed
and once again we really need to look at
the thumbnail
which he's photoshopped himself into
the embrace of pokemane and
the emoji the emoji is just over the top
with the scroll
scratching the head whoa
uh he just talks about the rumor that's
totally flat out false about her hiding
her
her boyfriend right yeah but i mean
there's no weight to it the thumbnail
alone is just creepy
it's so creepy yeah that i wanted to
show it
well and god's name is wrong with you
man no wonder the wife makes you sit in
the back seat and stay in the basement
you sleep in the basement dude i bet you
he's got a futon or some [ __ ] down there
because he sleeps down there half the
time my wife went out for pizza without
me
i know it's so unfair
it's so unfair so
that was so he's obsessed with pokeman
now this is when it gets
really weird you guys his obsession with
brie larson
is so beyond normal he has made close to
six
it's hard to tell because there's so
much footage but we calculate it must be
close to 60 videos
60 videos on brie larson and every
single one of them has her in the same
outfit
with tons of cleavage brie larson's
channel is dying
they have i mean that's his most popular
outfit user i mean there's a bunch of
them but yeah
60 videos brie larson's channel is dead
with the classic uh soflo antonio emoji
captain so
here's a look at some of the many videos
he's made about her
let's see bree larson's most unlikable
brie larson turned down brie larson
made a youtube channel and reactionaries
losers are seething
uh brie larson damage control
ruby rose goes for brie larson brie
larson barely and adventures critics say
captain marvel only gets 15 minutes
oh my goodness dude i mean who thinks
about brie larson this much
it's just so weird like why bree larson
of all of all people to obsessed over
it clearly has a disdain for women i
especially consider myself
the number one brie larson fan channel
yeah that's
super disturbing bro
fifty thousand bad captain marvel
reviews deleted and youtube hiding
no give me a break youtube is hiding
dude you are such a [ __ ] weirdo
but wait it gets better the first video
on jeremy's channel about brie larson
the origin of his infatuation
oh man
she let out yesterday with a cryptic
tweet
to entertainment weekly
hey entertainment weekly i'm bored want
to break the internet tomorrow
so everyone assumed that they i will say
and his
well i don't really think it's in his
defense but i do hate that phrase
i hate anybody who says break the
internet yeah it's bad we're going to
be releasing the captain marvel
uh trailer a movie that isn't for me
the comic book was terrible in my
opinion and brie larson is it just a
coincidence that he hates like all like
female leads black leads anyone there's
not a male guy as the main character
it's not for him a vile woman
that doesn't mean people can't enjoy her
film
i'm just choosing not to support it on
personal
reasons well she has not [ __ ] me
and that is the reason should i keep
watching or should i go
that's plenty okay that's fine some of
the issues he has with brie larson
include
bree's youtube channel is growing fast
because she's famous
i mean it's not that big it has 100 440
subs
she joins youtube uh he made a video
brie larson joins youtube she's totally
just like
us except better bree
supposedly has a butt double and she
lies about doing her own stunts
bro avengers cast savagely roasts brie
larson and her lies about doing her own
stunts
there's no way that that's a true title
uh her comments on race brie larson
totally doesn't
hate white men captain marvel isn't for
white
though did she say that she didn't say
that no she's talking about
diversity and the people reviewing the
movie yeah he hates diversity i can tell
that's a
thread should i watch this video it's
kind of a highlight
oh yeah it's a highlight of uh welcome
to youtube
yet another hollywood celebrity this
time
it's everybody's favorite creator brie
larson it is of course my prediction
that she has come to youtube
in order to take us all down
that's right because now that she's a
youtube content creator
she'll be protected by youtube's creator
on creator policies
so people can't make endless videos
mocking her like they could have before
dude you have 60 videos about her up on
your channel right now like
god you're such a like he's crying about
being a victim nothing's ha
he he by the very definition of his
existence disproves his whole victim
narrative
yeah he still pushes it coincidence
though that's right brie is here to stay
also like dude do you think she knows
who you are bro that she gives a [ __ ]
about you
the only reason she knows who you are is
because like a police officer tipped him
off
dipped her off her agent warren said hey
you might want to get a restraining
order against this guy
marketing blitz brie larson has that's
right youtube channel and therefore
that is extremely newsworthy so i will
cover it
first of all brie larson has already
gained uh 38 000 subscribers today i'm
sure she'll end the day
that's really not that big of a deal
dude
like her video has 17 000 views why are
you [ __ ] on her
at a million or more it's exactly what
you might expect brie larson
doing exactly what i would do in her
role flexing on all these youtube
content creators who are
uh who would thirst at the idea of
sharing their channel with brie larson
to help
launch hers she appeared on hot ones
this morning
near the end of her video she points out
that in her comment section
she says thank you for watching my first
youtube video
it was so great learning from all those
who
joined make sure to follow them leave a
comment letting me know which creators i
should work with as well
please free let's do a breakdown of your
captain marvel role who can forget
the fact that brie larson's own butt
had to have a stunt double if you
remember that there was a casting call
presumably for brie larson
a feature film mary lou but body double
working multiple days starting in
september
why might she what that's the evidence
is just some random casting call
but it's very normal by the way to do
that i don't know why
right that's normal people do that all
the time a butt double
i mean i don't know i mean only time
only
you know you're gonna have to really
wonder yeah dude you're not desperate to
[ __ ] her or anything
acting like she's got a flat ass such a
you are such an unfuckable
he's like the most unfuckable human on
earth
she might have but no i'm not but
shaming her i'm just saying
hey you know even your butt isn't real
in the film that doesn't seem very woke
brie larson this is back in june when i
made the video
promises i don't hate white dudes but
laments the lack of inclusion
among film critics i'm not judging you
if you want to see captain marvel
if you're interested in that film i for
one will not be seeing it because brie
larson thinks i'm overrepresented in
critics and assume presumably
overrepresented
in the people paying to see her movie
now it's a dude he is so
he's so reaching to be outraged he's so
social justice worry
oh well you think there's not enough uh
diversity in critics
well then there's then i'm not gonna i
mean a white man is not gonna pay to see
your film
bold marketing strategy to attack white
men
uh it didn't work great for ghostbusters
2016 maybe it will work for captain
marvel now captain marvel
has a gigantic gigantic budget for
marketing
they're in every movie i've seen in the
past six months they've had her trailer
and i'm sure the movie will do just fine
all right me not going to see it isn't
going to be a big deal
just like me not going to see uh you
know
thanks for the breakdown dude solo a
star wars soyeri uh didn't really affect
them that much
although soy reads it but i for one i'm
not going to give money to somebody
who is clearly a racist and a sexist
individual because
she's not actually concerned about i
mean what's more racist saying that
there's not a diversity
enough diversity in film credits or
saying that gay pride month is about
dudes butt [ __ ]
or wanting to write for the daily caller
which is a
has a countdown timer on their homepage
to the white genocide
getting fair and accurate reviews she
wants her reviews done by
people of a certain gender and people of
a certain color and by
definition that is racism and sexism so
i have no interest in giving money to
brie larson
given her disgusting views
on uh people okay
i mean yeah that that's quite a stretch
dude
well oh so that so we as we've
established
she's made um 60 videos on brie larson
one of her central criticisms is that
she's a celebrity on youtube trying to
be like hey look at me i'm just one of
the
i'm one of the beautiful people
celebrate me
so it would stand to think that will
smith who's like really the greatest
perpetrator of that
who has nine million subscribers uh
would work would also you know be under
the wrath of the quartering let's see
how many videos he's made about will
smith
zero zero videos about will smith
how come he don't want me man
[Music]
you know i mean i mean i don't know is
that i think that's pretty telling that
he hasn't made a single video about will
smith
yeah i i when i was digging around i did
manage to find
a single tweet that kind of offhandedly
mentioned him in passing of that being
cringy but um
yeah no videos 60 brie larson
zero will smith
fortnite yeah
by the way her channels are not even
that big dude they had like 400 000
subscribers will smith is in [ __ ]
youtube rewind saying fortnight ah
so i mean come on how does he not get
one video it's rewind time
rewind time fortnite ah
that's hot it's rewind that's hot
anyway oh that's hot jeremy
really wants to talk to brie oh my god
he tweets at her and tagged her on
twitter i am offering brie larson the
opportunity to speak about these
comments
comments nearly 500 000 potential film
reviewers would love to know more about
if she really doesn't hate white men
that she will grant me just
20 minutes via skype i'll work around
her schedule
s-i-m-p good call uh
miss dr mr phil new video he this is in
response to his video
captain marvel is not for white men he
called it please re
pre he's begging his fans please share
this
she says it's not for white men even
publicly she tries to say that she
totally doesn't hate is this what we
watched
yeah because that's literally not even
close to what happened in the video
she's she's not she's talking about film
reviewers not
audience members and she just is asking
for
more diversity he he even she even
publicly tries to say she totally
doesn't hate white men but her actions
and words prove she's a sexist racist
please share this
bro the fact that he tweeted at her is
the most sad
[ __ ] ever and tagged her 130 likes
okay this is when it takes a turn for
like bates motel
this should actually really disturb me
[Music]
jeremy bought a shed with the money he
made from all of his brie larson videos
he calls it
the bree shed
okay yeah uh so yeah it's a 12 by 12
shed
if you want to play the video so this
video is called brie larson bought me
something amazing
here's the video so obviously a lot of
people
gave me a lot of grief for making so
many videos about
brie larson on you know the thing is
that they didn't understand is that
i'm a huge fan bree knows i'm a huge fan
and that's why she sent me such a
wonderful gift
thank you for you know a lot of people
said hey you made 20 videos on brie
larson are you obsessed
no no no no i was giving the people what
they wanted
and because of that look at what
bree sent me a beautiful brief shed
now i need to do a little bit of
landscaping around the sides which i'm
hoping
this brie larson film video will cover
but let's just do a little cribs tour of
the wonderful
brie shot
now if you think now this if you think
this is reminiscent
of a snuff film just wait for the next
slide
this is a beautiful 12 by 12 slab
i'm gonna install some rafters up here
okay
so he's got the breeze shed now let's
see
where this now something to be
considered okay
brie larson won an oscar for the movie
room
where she trapped in a shed
and sexually assaulted over and over
here is the shed from the room
you can see this is the shed
this is the bree shed he bought to taunt
her
now considering everything we've talked
about is it really a coincidence
can it really be considered a stretch to
think that maybe he's making a reference
to a shed in a film where she was raped
and sexually assaulted over and over and
held a prisoner
i mean is it really a reach
i'm not sure
he always talks about his breeze shed
i mean more stuff happens in sheds than
just putting a lawnmower a fan
you know probably really got him in that
shed right his wife
just he's like sleeping there [ __ ]
the house stinks like urine pee outside
like you [ __ ] animal
that's a good point in my basement yeah
you think
you think bree bought that for you you
know your wife controls all the finances
you don't even have a credit card bro
you know you pat you hand over the check
of your adsense every month
ah wow all right closing statements ain
what do you think about brie larson's
shed and about the sim seldom and
everything please
defend your client better than the other
two times
i don't know man i may have to give my
license back
oh you don't want to be a lawyer anymore
i may have to
this might be it you're ready to leave
the courtroom
you're ready you're saying your client
is so difficult to defend you are ready
to retire as a lawyer
i just i just can't i got nothing
my battery's low and so is my spirit
well let me ask you do you think it's a
coincidence the beat that he bought a
shed called the bree shed that has a on
on
a very striking resemblance to a shed in
a movie where she was repeatedly raped
and held prisoner a brie shed
that looks identical to a shed from her
most popular
film where he calls it the british hit
and keeps a poster over inside of it
yeah that's probably just a coincidence
it sounds like you're on our team it
sounds like you're on the prosecution's
team you wanna
you wanna cross over to his side
i mean i i can never be on your side uh
judge klein but
you know i may just walk away from the
whole thing
no side no man's land
well let me ask you something let me ask
you some specific questions what do you
think
i i got nothing either
say you understand my struggle a b would
you like to uh
close with any statements i mean
yeah i don't think i really need a
closing uh
statement but i do have a little theory
as we're going through this
i i'm kind of curious if he just
maybe he he just hates his wife and he's
taking it out on brie larson
and all this is just built up hate um
well he clearly he has a problem with
females i mean generally when people
have
something deep-seated like that it
probably it goes back to childhood
you know i mean i i don't i'm not gonna
first of all i'm not a professional and
i don't know but if i had to guess here
uh
you know as a as a judge as a judge and
it is my place to speculate on the
psyche of the
obviously all good judges speculate on
and diagnose their
those on trial but i would say he
probably you know
has a problem with his mom freud would
say and
it's led him down a path of surrounding
himself with with women that
he despises right his wife makes him
sleep in the basement and peed down a
drain
until it's the stump was too heavy that
she bought his ass a shed
and moved him literally outside like an
animal
she goes to pizza without him say no
more and he has to sit in the back seat
he sits in the back seat who does that
okay he's a quarter of a man
some would say he's a quarter of a man
some would say he's a quarter of a brain
some would say he's got
a quarter of an inch fully torqued
he shoots a quarter load with the lotion
a quarter load there we go
um well it doesn't sound like there's
much to talk about guys i have will say
that
i think we've come to a verdict here
let's summarize
reviewing the evidence of some celery
again it's overwhelming an
unhealthy obsession with any beautiful
girl he deems
um unattainable to him
and his fellow red pellet held in cells
you can be an insulin be married by the
way trust me his wife
definitely does not have sex with him so
he is an incel
in fact he may still be a virgin i don't
know the nature of the relationship
he has 20 gay dads by the way
he was raised by an army of gay black
men
[Music]
uh he is unhealthily obsessed with
pokemane
for sure even as far to to photoshop
himself and her loving embrace
he is unworldly stalkerishly obsessed
with brie larson
making close to 60 videos about her
using the revenue to buy a shed
he calls the bree shed which has an
uncanny likeness to her most popular
film that she won academy award with
where she was held prisoner and
repeatedly
molested
now if i was brie i would probably be
worried about this man and
seek probably a restraining order if i
was the wife of the quartering
i know she doesn't watch his videos but
she might want to start seeing what he's
up to on the internet
uh you know in short he is guilty man
he is guilty on all charges
[Music]
i sentence you to never use a toilet
again
you will be pooping [ __ ] and peeing
down the drain
for all of eternity
and uh you will live outside like an
animal in the shed
and i think that uh you're probably a
virgin and
i think it will stay that way till the
uh your
your parting days
thank you let's peed in my basement
just remember guys being married doesn't
mean you're not a virgin
i have proof at least i have a child
okay so unless i see proof he's a virgin
until
otherwise noted
alrighty well that about sums it up
thank you everybody for joining us here
today on content court
we have found the quartering guilty on
all charges is
charges and we wish you all a happy
and safe and justice-filled
week i want to thank the prosecution av
i want to thank ai ian who basically has
retired as an attorney today
he has thrown in the robe and the books
and everything
and i want to thank everybody zach and
dan for making this
possible thank you everybody
what is today today's tues tuesday yes
no so this so we'll see on friday for
after dark
[Music]
you